[Music]
the trump administration closed up shop
this week but
of course there was craziness until the
very end now
all the craziest things that happened at
the white house over the last few weeks
took place behind closed doors but some
details have come out you're welcome
i'm sorry who are you well i was a fly
on the wall the white house last week
and i heard
everything wow
that's crazy but why do you keep rubbing
your hands together
i'm about to eat some feces yuck
what it's fresh out of a butt that's
disgusting
well it's not nearly as gross as what i
heard in the oval office last week
oh yeah what'd you hear get this
trump had a meeting in the oval office
where he talked about declaring
martial law can you believe that no
that's hideous and that meeting was with
the my pillow guy
ew gross i know
oh what's what's happening oh nothing
i'm just
just regurgitating some enzymes that
dissolve my food so that i can slurp up
the sludge
oh come on man gross oh give me a break
i only lived for a month
you are so nasty oh i'm nasty
you know what's really nasty trump asked
the pentagon if he could have a
military-style send-off parade
on inauguration day while biden was
being sworn in
oh yuck yeah tell me about it
you gonna eat that eat what
hey
you need to leave oh come on i didn't
even get to the gnarliest most hideous
part yet
fine what's the gnarliest most hideous
part
the gnarliest most hideous part was when
trump referred to people who stormed the
capitol
as very special damn that is gnarly and
hideous
i'm so glad that idiot's gone i know
oh damn it
i just realized i forgot to pick up the
maggots from the barf
what my wife told me it was my day to
pick up our larva from a pile of puke
and i just
i totally blanked oh man i bet they're
really rising
i don't want to know any more details
about your life
good because between you and me i'm a
little buzzed right now
too much alcohol too much poop get out
of here
oh gross everything about you is gross
i i don't know why he walked instead of
flying like a lot he can fly away
he's blown away but he walked but he
walked away he's probably too drunk on
[Music]
poop
[Music]
you